peace be with you welcome to the Dean
show for those that were with us last
week Hamza met Ted Ted met Hamza the
human connection we were sharing TEDx
and some questions was going really
great so this is the part two to that
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
this is
this is the this is the video this is
the days of the things you mean you know
this is the things back here in the be
show one of the unique things about the
Dean show is that along with sharing
this message clearing the misconceptions
we really define the words here I want
you to start off this session with Ted
defining what is because we've thrown
around Muslim Islam what are these words
what do they mean what is this la même
well Aslam essentially means the
submission the piece was submission to
God and a Muslim is someone who
peacefully submits to the will of God he
says my will comes from my ego God's
will comes from training that transcends
that he is the source of peace as Salam
he is the loving he is the merciful so
I'm going to submit my will to his world
peacefully and I'm going to surrender to
him it's like almost letting go of your
ego she was saying you know what it's
about me and a lot of having that
connection what if someone says well
Christianity or Judaism or Buu doesn't
mean the same thing can you actually say
that oh Buddhism for example nice to be
like a Buddhist I still of the Tibetan
tradition you should be a Buddhist why I
used to get involved in the typical
tradition my brother was very involved
in this kind of agnostic Buddhist
philosophy is very interesting in some
parallels with Buddhism and Islam based
on you know thinking and ethical
reflection and to the book pondering
it's in the Islamic tradition with one
scholar dr. Malik Badri he basically
says that maybe Buddhism was one of the
monotheistic traditions and he would
somehow over you know like whispers you
know when human beings whisper from one
to another it gets filled you know again
change things change it's not I'm not
very different I'm assuming that I would
I would assume and this is a gross
assumption yeah I didn't grow up and I
haven't been around for sixteen hundred
years
in this conversation in that the Islam
that was worked with even in the
medieval times versus the conversation
that is today that just like everyone
else it has evolved to subsist so if I'm
asking the question if it's a question
much like Buddhism is it was this a
monotheistic thing yes of course what is
what is the conception of what you see
to come based on that where we've been
okay it's a very good question answer
this question just so real quick just
finishing so the people can understand
like you define what Islam is is Buddha
named after Buddha
yeah Christianity Christos very good
moving back to the Paul that's great
question
what ISM is the agnostic philosophy
meaning that there's one narration
attribute to the Buddha and someone
system does God exist and he said it's
irrelevant right so basically the
question of God and his relevancy is a
non question from the that perspective
because Buddhism is an agnostic
philosophy just work with your life your
mind how do you break your ego how do
you live peacefully now we would say
actually the good question is a very
important question should because it
grounds your morality it grounds who you
are your sense of self and all of these
different things nobody comes to
Christianity a Christian basically
especially mainstream Christianity they
believe in something what you will call
a Trinitarian conception of God in the
current in the Greek language is OMA
osios there's one essence or Marussia
we'll see is as one essence three
distinct persons well we would say
humbly in the Islamic tradition this
doesn't fit the majesty perfection of
God and this is not the correct
conception of the divine so if we to
connect with that is that connecting
with something other than the divine so
what we would say humbly is if you want
to go back to the roots go back to even
original Christianity Christianity the
original belief so even further back
yeah even the Irish tradition way back
yet you want to connect with God there
is no intermediary no Sun no book no
Pope nothing it's a direct connection a
direct relationship and that's why
sometimes you have
you know brothers and Christianity
saying you know how's your relationship
with God do you have a loving
relationship with God I would humbly say
well I don't think you do because maybe
you know if you have to have something
in the middle is that a loving
relationship if I want to like fall in
love with my wife
I'm going to put my mother in middle
right oh oh you know stop knows that's a
horrible plan if you ever going to work
with my phone and talk to my wife that's
not gonna work
so I'm gonna connect straight to my wife
just like with volume and have a loving
religion it straight to him so that's
what it sounds about we connect with was
your question now how do we know Islam
hasn't changed just like many
observations motivation no there's
there's there's here's some things that
I've come to understand historically and
let's just look at the civilization in
it it's basically it's been like a
writing on a snowboard down a mountain
mankind right if we have a launches but
if you you have from pretty significant
ones yes so we we drifted deeply into
our first understandings of religion and
we had many many things that we chose to
choose as a things we'd understand God's
there were animals we wanted there
Morfitt ism we have the pagan religions
that are that it's you know there's an
admiration of the animal world and
there's a lot of what we did in our
lives at that time that was very
animalistic it sure and then we come
into our philosophers began to say hang
on guys we don't have a god of lightning
we don't have and and Greek myths
mythology and then these great thinkers
come to play and say hang on a second
and too many too many divine beings here
we've got to get this down to something
people that's eligible and something we
can live with so that drifts into the
next big swing it becomes a scientific
pursuit via philosophy then it's
swinging it's up and down its drifting
extremely towards the spiritual side
extremely towards the scientific side
and we have Darwinism that brings in
this level we if we can literally change
the breed of dog and change the way
flowers look how is that how is God in
charge of everything if I can control
the flowers that grow
that's a fantastic question it births
some interesting thing there's a few
questions here right yeah a lot of saris
go back to the first question which is
no one I mentioned about Buddhism and
about the statements actually be to you
and the preservation to love Islam is
like different it's not based on a
whispers philosophy in Islamic tradition
is called something called motor water
or tea water it's an Arabic word all it
means is recurrent reporting and I want
to try and give you a picture free to
put in your mind say you have the
Prophet Muhammad upon whom be peace
right and he told something to five of
his companions and these five companions
said exactly the same thing to their
five companions sure and each of these
five companions that have five
companions they say to another five
companions something else so the chain
grows and you see that the chain of
knowledge not everybody has the same
chain so somebody has this chain someone
has this chain some of these people
never met before they come from
different times and places but at the
end of the chain you have millions of
people saying exactly the same thing
sure I philosophically speaking to say
that what they're saying now wasn't what
the Prophet Muhammad upon whom be peace
said is tantamount to a mask conspiracy
and they're somehow basically traveled
took a time machine
you know said make sure you see this
make sure you say that you got it from
this chain and say you got it from that
chain of narration sure sure so this
basically shows that you can't deny what
you call recurrent reporting even David
Hume famous Scottish skeptic philosopher
he said you know if the masses of people
in the 1600s masses of people in the
1600s actually said that there was eight
days of darkness and he was reported by
everybody from different peoples and
different types of cases then to deny
this with your absurd he was a skeptic
even denied causality in a way right
sure so this is an Islamic historical
principle and all of the prophetic
traditions that even though
has come by this scientific method oil
there's a long scientific method this
historical principle so to deny a
statement of the Prophet Muhammad that's
authenticated upon you be peace and to
deny the Quran is acadec denying Plato
Aristotle world war one world war to
ensure all the known history so that's
why we have a very preserve tradition
it's very very exciting I'm you know I
don't want to cut them up but we got to
go to break and we'll be right back with
more hair in the Dean show double
anywhere please subscribe to the dgo
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Dean show Hamza tell us in
my studies in comparative religion I
have not found any other book that a has
been preserved tamper free tamper proof
like the Quran preserved in the original
Arabic language with the challenge as
you stated earlier if you find one
contradiction god almighty is saying in
the Quran that it can't be from God but
do you find any other book making the
claim like it does on every page you see
Allah God's name mentioned and you see
that now it's claiming that look I am
your Creator I created the universe try
to disprove it if you can't then it's
not from me do you do we find that in
the Bible do you find that in Buddhism I
have not found it do you mind admits the
money to know what you understand the
point I do like the Quran basically
makes it shines like a falsification
test it says in the second chapter 23rd
verse my income to Arabia minimum is an
euler abdun and it continues basically
if if you're in doubt about this book we
have sent down to our servant referring
to the Prophet Muhammad upon whom be
peace and bring one chapter like it
right also the Quran says in the same
chapter that if this wasn't from God
they'll be if he laughs and Cathy
meaning many discrepancies you know very
interesting about this term by the way
low of its off the topic but it's
relates it says to be many discrepancies
so there's two things you could do first
you could look at the hold of Quran and
see if there's any discrepancies that's
the four way or if you're logician you
can find out how many times the word
discrepancy is mentioned did I find in
that form join mention once
anyway so the point here is smart he's
very smart right so the thing with the
Quran it makes this challenge she
doesn't hide and say just have blind
faith just just believe because I said
so
it challenges mankind addresses man it
dresses Ted how a dress should be
addressed your you have a brain you have
a heart use it they got a saying look
here's this text
it didn't come fourteen hundred years
ago is making amazing claims for itself
sure by saying here's a challenge if you
don't believe this from the Creator then
discuss it challenge it engage with it
and what I would argue is that this
forms a basis for a whole array of
arguments and things that we can assert
that this book is from the divine let me
give you one very small just to get the
thinking going right the Quran was
revealed of a twenty three year period
this is a historical fact it was ruled
in peace no over 23 years for specific
times and places then it was put
together as al khattab as a book as a
physical text now if it was revealed
about twenty three year period for
specific times and places then I want to
ask a question how on earth does it have
its structural and mathematical
coherence take for example the second
chapter it has two hundred and eighty
six verses the chapter was ruled of a
nine year period
intensity of a two year period right now
if you do a karate chop in the middle
you have the hundred and forty third
verse do you know where do you find
middle now this is interesting
now go to the third chapter it says the
likeness of Jesus is like the likeness
of Adam because it was an argument from
the Christians write that book you know
he had no father therefore his father's
good which we don't believe right and
Allah is saying wait wait a minute but
the likeness of Jesus like the likeness
of Adam you've been even Adam he had no
father but you don't say that God's his
father he said he was created by God
right now the key word here is likeness
because Adam is mentioned 25 times in
the Quran
and so as Jesus mentioned 25 times in
the crime you know what's interesting up
to this verse the both mentioned seven
times each and that for me is remarkable
now there's no for example if you go to
the shortest chapter surah al kelsa
there's only three lines and remember
the Quran says bring one chapter like it
it has ten legs Amata like scimitar
units of meaning a unit of meaning is
not just a word you kind of a
preposition with a word right correct
you have ten units of meaning what's
interesting is each rest uses only ten
letters and what's even more interesting
is that the whole chapter uses only ten
letters one's right to consider the
Hansa as a partial letter it's not a
real letter Saigon quasi letter that's
very interesting
and there are many more of these kind of
structural features so for me the
product Muhammad upon whom be peace
didn't have a computer didn't have a
calculator can even write things down
now what's very interesting is that
these verses were ruled over twenty
three year period yet we didn't have a
computer but it was compiled together to
have this amazing structural coherence
for me humbly I don't think there's a
naturalistic explanation
that's as one now there is another one
take for example revealing of what
historical knowledge the Quran many
claims saves boring from the Jewish
tradition in the Bible right but this is
force for one specific reason the Bible
mentions Pharaoh the Torah mentions
Pharaoh the Quran which is Pharaoh big
deal but also the Quran mentions King
for the leader of the Egyptians also and
it mentions in a distinct way it
mentions Pharaoh at the time of Moses
and al-malik
King at the time of Yusuf Joseph and
doesn't conflate them doesn't use as no
conflicts no timeline yes but in the
biblical tradition and the Jewish
tradition this is conflict right oh it's
from the full truth in every subtle book
it's not accurate from that perspective
I was purposefully inaccurate this is
now this is a minut detail if you were
to take away this word you want to
affect the message of the Quran however
it remains distinct that images Pharaoh
for the time of Moses came to the time
of Joseph's firm but the question here
is this at that time we had no access to
the hieroglyphics which was the patrol
language of the Egyptians it was a dead
language
we have no old tradition of historic no
culture that even knew that language at
that period it was dead
now I advise and regarding that
particular part and this is this is the
part that I I don't I don't even pretend
to first of all I've learned a great
deal about the Quran and just this very
short elegant elegant explanation thank
you for that and in that I'll add that
I've never doubted the fact that it's
amazing in and of itself as a creation
as a book it's a fantastic demonstration
and I also if I'm correct me if I'm
wrong is it not taught through song it's
like a recital thank you a recital and
song now I didn't grow up in England I
have a year and a half nearly two year
old little girl I have a song that I
heard there once was to do from York we
had a hundred men yes he marched them up
to the top of the hill and then down to
the bottom again when they were half way
up there and either up nor down and it's
it's the same thing over and over
another good rendition right well yeah I
totally die butchered it because you
know it was a guy I know I'm gonna hurry
that vocal 9-1-1 whose mood I think I've
completely committed a crime against
that song which would probably be my
very first introduction to Islam it's
been very difficult for me to do it
amount of elegance such as your
obviously I'm grateful for that we're
gonna take a break now and we'll be
right back with more for our last
segment here on a detail don't go
anywhere please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show please Hamza go ahead
and take off you were explaining about
the historic about the historical for
solo hieroglyphics was a dead language
and we found out the rosetta stone which
was a stone that enabled us to translate
the hieroglyphics and I think the end of
the 20th century
and when we understood the hieroglyphics
we find out that actually the Bible the
Torah wrong and the Koran is accurate
specifically because in the old Middle
Kingdom which was the time of Joseph
they were using the kind of title as the
King for the need of the Egyptians and
then the New Kingdom was a time of Moses
they start to call him the Pharaoh which
I believe means the great house that is
distinct my new detail now when did the
Prophet get his knowledge from upon me
peace when there was an ignorance of
that knowledge an abscess about
knowledge we can't find it anywhere over
tradition or in texture tradition you
can find a historical book serving
religious tradition so the claim that he
covered the Bible was quite interesting
because therefore fine maybe he covered
the Bible but then he corrected his
mistakes well I didn't know there were
mistakes and how'd he get the correct
information from so that's another
little signpost to accumulate you have
an accumulative case for the Quran
another quick thing at interpreters I
couldn't mention ten points if we don't
have time but other thing is about the
structural features of the Quran many of
the chapters on what you call a ring
composition now you don't need to know
Arabic for this ring compositions like
units of themes categories of themes
again let's look at the second chapter
is the largest chapter
it has theme a theme b c d e then you
have D one you have C one you have V 1
and a 1 so you have this ring
composition a and a 1 have a similar
theme B and b1 have a similar theme C
and C 1 have a similar theme D and D 1
have a similar theme and E is on its own
II mentions the present before a
mentions the past after E mentions the
future but yet you will have these
similar themes right this is ring
composition and each ring each category
has its own ring composition as well so
it's structured based on meaning and
structural themes
and for me since this book was reviled
about 23 appeared four specific times
and addresses specific events how on
earth has it been developed in this
structural way it shows that the author
knew the feature which again gives
support to the fact that it's likely to
be from the divine is this possibly and
I ask this in a really curious at this
enough time that is it not a possibility
to have because of being written over a
23-year span of time that the ability to
ascertain cyclical occurrences much like
the seasons much like the growing of
crops much like the coming and going of
leadership much like the migration of
crops and animals that within this span
of time to write the accountants of up
to a singular point and then also write
the accountants of what they believe
will come to pass based off of this
evidence having seen that cycle come to
a close and the next natural thing for
life to do is to repeat itself are we
not seeing something potentially being
described here in the Quran as the
natural order of the cyclical T of life
yes oh that's a good question I think
the only problem with that is that
wrinkle position is not a new thing oh
we want to assume that they wrote that
not having our education we're
definitely not yet smart about the same
thing people in literature developed
structures called ring composition sure
the only problem is it's almost
impossible to develop ring composition
if you're addressing new realities over
your career of prophetic career your
religious career if you like ring
composition works if you make a story up
right but this was events that happened
and the verses that were dressing those
specific events okay now for it to have
almost like a prearranged structure it's
as if you knew what events were going to
happen which was almost impossible well
we look down upon that today with
someone that could tell us that in the
year 2022 we're gonna have this happen
by the way in the year yet there is a
prophetic notion to most of what's time
well but whether we're not talked about
talking about the future it's not
prophesies he's talking about if this
happens then do this right okay yeah all
of these verses were specific to context
and time menu okay and now I get it yes
you have this recomposition
it was almost a manual to in in response
to these conditions in life this is the
best path I take and yet has this
amazing structure of those Ruda between
tolerating the other thing I want to
mention is rebbit relevancy now the
Quran basically wants to address the
human mind the seventh century mind the
15th century mind in the 30th century -
certainly and let me give you some
examples to show the multi-layered and
multi-leveled meaning of this book which
is phenomenal because if it was seventh
century it must have a seventh century
language but the crown is so dynamic it
has almost a timeless language of for me
it shows it came from a being that knows
all knowledge take for example the word
ilaha ilallah means blood clot or an
embryo or something all certainly part
of the human development and you can
find it in chapter 14 chapter 23 verse
14 now the word Alaka has five major
meanings blood blood in a general sense
a blood clot in Leitrim or clay that
sticks to the hang or something that
clings now for the seventh century Arab
he knew that based on dissections and
abortions in the embryo were like a
blood clot certainly so the Quran is
saying look you were this and now you're
here look at the wisdom in the universe
there must be a creator he deserves to
be questioned but if you fast forward in
the fifteenth century we developed a
microscope and we look into the
microscope day 20 to 25 what do we see
we see the embryo it looks like a worm
dr. Dale layman in his book and that to
me demystified said looks like a worm
which is another interpretation of the
word exactly so it relates to that
mochila word meaning but then after you
you may not have a scientific meaning
because science changes Shira science
could be wrong right well that's the
whole point of science it's not to test
and then continue walking but this is
the beautiful thing forget the empirical
scientific understanding take a
spiritual understanding and say well
maybe God is not talking about anything
scientific maybe it's existential
referring to the self being was here
before our thought about being was here
he's saying that we were leech he's
saying that you're like a parasite
you had a parasitic relationship with
your mother if you study embryology you
see that the baby drains the resource of
his mother certainly and the leech if he
were to be sucking my hand now it drains
my resources it takes everything it
needs from my blood and from the get-go
both the leech and the embryo act in
this parasitic away drains from the
resources of its host mother I yeah my
hand in this case now what's very
interesting professor Lord Winston from
Imperial College University said exactly
the same thing he's an embryo and each
act in the same way
she's as if the Quran is saying hey you
mister arrogant mr. businessman mr.
think you know it all mister
self-sufficient you were dependent on
your own mother and ultimately your
mother and everything in creation is
dependent on God so willfully and
willingly lo the wind of humility and
message to your mother because dreaming
peacefully and willingly and
compassionately drained her resources
for you you are leech so there may be a
spiritual perspective
now the reason giving these examples is
because isn't it amazing and fascinating
although you have a limited scope of
meaning for certain words in the Quran
they addresses of 7th century mindset a
15th century mindset and a 21st century
mindset for me that's a dynamic text and
that's a very important aim is give you
one final example one for example
the Quran says that the Sun and the moon
have their own orbits right they swim
the word is yes bhajana
now you can look into the universe as
with your naked eye as the seventh
century Arab of sandals and say wow
they're swimming in the cosmos well that
could also relate to celestial mechanics
they have an author when it's on orbit
but you may be thinking the Sun has its
own orbit yes the seventh century Arab
believed that the Sun was going around
the earth which is wrong but it is them
in tality that was a hiccup in time well
7 that is to address their mentality to
make the realizes power and wisdom in
the universe but you was very
interesting the Sun does have its own
orbit according to modern physics or
modern physics is talking about it
orbits the Milky Way and it takes 220
million years to Auburn if you look at
amazing diagrams of the universe the Sun
is doing this all Ben there's things and
the planets are going around it it's
phenomenal so do you understand one word
addresses a solar century mindset 15 and
38 and any century mindset so for me it
seemed to me when you add all these
accumulative things together past the
life of the Prophet Muhammad upon me
please there is another question
and maybe another show then it should
make you think I say what's the best
explanation for this we're almost out of
time we got one minute left
closing comments and advice to those
truth seekers people are curious like
Ted and let's say someone out there is
hearing this what is that first step
when some because we know that in Islam
you know it's a lifetime struggle to
acquire knowledge there's so much as an
ocean of knowledge but when somebody
wants to do Islam they want to accept
Islam what is the first major step that
one has to take well what they have to
do is affirm the truth reality you have
an amazing time Aslam is like saying
that you have an amazing time and that's
why we're saying we're affirming the
reality that you have an amazing time
and what is the phone affirmation of
reality here la ilaha illaallah
muhammaden-rasul allah there is no deity
no object worthy of worship but the one
that created us the date Allah and there
and the Prophet Muhammad upon me peace
is his final messenger now this should
be made with your heart that you
sincerely believe in this and that you
have a willingness to worship if you
don't have that willingness to worship
which is your eyes own d'être as a
french say your reason for existence
then that cannot that might not be
accepted so you have a willingness to
worship to come close to God and you
believe in that reality and that makes
your Muslim and not it simple you don't
have to know all these complex stuff I
was talking about Judaism for you
to come down with fireworks or anything
it's so yesterday on Friday we're here
there was a sister American sister sat
through the lecture came up to me said I
want to become Muslim by Iran what's
going on she thought there has to be a
special time a moment I said look Allah
wants you to love him but you've closed
the door on Allah
you've looked to go put the gates up and
put guard dogs Allah wants you to love
him there's nothing special do you like
this guy's shoes yeah I like his shoes
Islam is just like that you're accepting
a reality there is no deity worthy of
worship I'm not my day t so strike is
not my dating my boss is not my day t
Eddie's on my day t tends not my day t
the ISM and schizos on my day T my date
is the one who created me want the one
that loves me the one that knows you
better than I know myself and I'm gonna
submit to that and I'm gonna love Allah
and he wants to love me so why would I
choose hell over a loving God God
doesn't send you there Allah says don't
blame me blame your own hand it's the
spiritual cause and effect so a lie
saying just from your free will make the
right choice and I told her unlock the
door who move the dog take away the gate
open the door and just embrace the love
of Allah she became a Muslim on Friday
it was beautiful right and that's what
that's advice to everybody life is
simple we complicated sometimes of
egocentrism and philosophy and all this
rubbish but it's a simple you were made
this is very basic instinct is a
rational principle you're made by
something that's supernatural
he sent down a message and we have good
reasons to believe in it you submit to
his will and you're at peace you know as
safe to anybody you know a service to
anyone apart from God and if you're in
service to God you're in service to
mankind you create justice and peace and
harmony and then you die then you have
eternal bliss and paradise and that's a
rule for everybody
right time we're going over our time any
closing comments stating who you are
I think you've taught us a lot because
it shows to everybody the Muslims that
we could come together have these
discussions like go in a coffee shop
chilling out
to start discussing about man life in
the universe and I'm going to connect
with you after this anyway because you
know we had a long conversation before
we had this show and you're a great guy
keep up the fitness and the nutrition
all the stuff that you do keep up the
reading and this engage further that's
what we have to do we have to show
people we have to transcend the FoxNews
narrative now that they will divide us
people want to divide us we want to say
you in a space but we could have the
right emotions the right intellectual
discussions the right human connection
so we could talk about these issues and
if we disagree we disagree with love we
don't disagree with hate and that's what
we want Eddie right yes absolutely thank
you thank you thank you very much thank
you thank you everybody for tuning in
and we'll see you next time here on the
Dean show hope you enjoy please please
subscribe to the DCO follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below